The Joe Rogan Experience what happened
with the Folsom story is that there was
a
there was a flash flood on a river
called the dry Cimarron River in the
August of 1908
and in the aftermath of that flash flood
this African-American cowboy
named Charles mcjunkin is out riding
fence for one of the local ranchers
seeing what he's going to have to repair
and as he's riding along his horse
suddenly pitches up and its Hooves slide
in the mud right to the edge of this
freshly cut about 30 foot chasm in the
slope
that he's writing and when he leans out
of his saddle
and looks down into this this cut
what he sees
are bones of a gigantic size that he's
never seen before I mean this is a guy
who
he had been on the buffalo hunting
planes back in the 1870s so he had seen
Buffalo butchered he knew what bones
from big animals look like but these
were giant bones
and so this guy mcjunkin started trying
to call attention to the site
he never was able to do so and get any
archaeologist out or paleontologists out
to look at it he dies in 1922 but about
four years after his death
this museum curator from Denver a guy
named Jesse figgins comes down and
brings a crew down and I mean what
figgins is interested in he's sort of an
amateur guy himself he's just interested
in some fancy big bones for his Museum
up in Denver
but his crew starts digging into this
site
and they began uncovering these giant
bison what they're finding is a side of
Bison antiquis these giant bison that
became extinct about 10 000 years ago
the ones that the Folsom people had
particularly specialized in hunting
and as they're Excavating this site in
the first summer they come across just
sort of lying in the debris a couple of
points like they've never seen before
which are
three or four inches long and have these
thin flutes on either side at the base
there's one right there's yeah there's
one right there
the Folsom point so what figgins is guys
realize is that the hurdle for
convincing the world the scientific
hurdle for convincing the world that
humans had been present in America at
the time everybody thought
Indians had only been in America for
maybe a couple of thousand years before
Europeans got here
but the hurdle was finding an extinct
animal out of the pleistocene
indicating that it had been killed by
human technology while the animal was
still alive
and the next summer I mean it happened
to be a summer when the Smithsonian had
just published an article by some fancy
archaeologist saying you know North
America has no Antiquity in its history
Indians have only been here for at most
2 000 years probably less than that
and within about two months that article
coming out
This Crew finds the scapula of one of
these bison they're Excavating with one
of these Clovis points embedded three
quarters of the way into the bone
and at that point they stopped digging
they call on all the famous
archaeologists in the United States a
guy named Alfred kitter was the most
famous archaeologist in America at the
time and he comes takes a look and
proclaims this
one of the greatest discoveries in
American history
so they don't have radiocarbon dating
yet and nobody knows how old this is all
they know is that that particular bison
species has been extinct for quite a
while figgin says
this side is 400 000 years old
but when we finally do get radio carbon
dating about two decades later it looks
as if a band of Folsom Hunters using add
adults using spear throwers
had killed 32 bison anticos in what had
once been a box canyon on the Southern
Plains 12 450 years ago and so suddenly
that Discovery in the early 20th century
in the 1920s gives America a kind of an
Antiquity that it had never had before
and within a decade we discover the
Clovis site which is out on the Texas
New Mexico border and the Clovis side is
of these elephant Hunters who are
actually even older than the Folsom
people and this pushes when they're
finally radiocarbon dated that site
pushes uh the dates back to the 13
000 year range so what these discoveries
in the 20s and 30s are finally
indicating that contrary to what most
Americans of the 20th century think
America is a brand new place
history dates to the time Europeans got
here in the 1600s uh
you know Indian people have only been
here a couple thousand years suddenly we
realize America is this really vastly
old place and that sets up the
subsequent story that I mean I try to
what I try to do I mean I was an English
major as an undergraduate so I'm kind of
drawn to narrative storytelling
uh telling a lot of stories and when you
write a book with about 66 million years
of History obviously had a lot of
opportunity to tell stories because
there are a lot of stories in a span of
time like that
what when you say that the Clovis points
and the Folsom points with the the
fluted uh part of it where so you could
attach a stick to it yeah there's no
people in Europe that figured this out
no this was a an American invention uh
what did they use in Europe they were
just using uh blade points sometimes
with uh with the ears at the bottom
so the ears yeah the ears so you have a
triangular point and it has two ears
coming out and you attach you use the
ears as a place to attach the Rawhide
and so this was metal
no not metal what were these Flint they
were using Flint as well so
so when they were making these points
they were just doing it in a different
way they were doing it a different way
so they'd figured out the same sort of
Technology kind of attaching a stick but
they had different methods that seemed
to just be human Ingenuity yeah when
when did they figure that out well they
certainly figured it out by uh what's
called the salutrient culture which is a
sort of a contemporary with Clovis
they're hunting big animals uh they're
hunting mammoths and rhinos and things
like that in Europe so that's in the 16
000 17 000 year range
yeah so this this fluted idea is a
distinctive North American invention is
there any difference in the quality of
the type of the stone that was
accessible to people in North America
versus Europe well I mean both places
had outcrops of flint and flint and
obsidian were the two two types of stone
you went for but
uh North America had some really great
flint and obsidian outcrops and one of
the things that's really pretty
fascinating about these Clovis people
about clovisia the beautiful and it's
and they were all over America by the
way there are more of their points
discovered in the Southeast and in New
England than there are in many places in
the west so this is not just a western
phenomenon this just happens to be where
we discovered them first but they were
all over America but they went for they
seem to be making pilgrimages to four or
five locations that had the absolute
best sharpest hardest Flint in America
and they would go back to those spots
again and again and again kind of had a
in their minds a mental geography of
where these locations were wow yeah so
they one of the great things about the
whole Clovis period to a little lesser
extent Folsom is that
there are these spectacular blades that
they did and sometimes they would do
blades that were like eight or nine or
ten inches long and there are some of
them caches of some of these Blades of
that size that indicate they were never
used they basically were kind of
ceremonial objects I mean I kind of
argue in the book I mean it's pretty
much speculation because we don't really
know a huge amount about these people
but one of the things I I argue is that
unlike in Western Europe they didn't
leave us Grand cave art of these animals
that they were hunting
it's almost as if
their tools were their art
and it was their tools kind of
represented uh this
ultimate technology
this Sublime technology that they would
actually create in some form in blaze
that they never really used to hunt just
to have as ceremonial objects wow so
it's a I mean it's a really fascinating
Story I mean we've known about the
Clovis people obviously for a long time
we've been trying to figure out of
course other explanations for what
happened to the animals of the pleistene
because we lost a lot of them during the
pleistocene and people have proposed all
sorts of other theories
but one of the strange things about this
story I mean I tried to do a book that's
based on all the latest science I could
find and all the best people who were
doing archeology and paleontology and
genomic science I mean that's one of the
possibilities these days it's we have
genomic science that's able to tell us
things now that we've never known even
over the last 15 or 20 years
and one of the fascinating things about
it is that
it's almost like climate change
we've tried to come up with every other
possible explanation
to let ourselves off the hook for
climate change
but it almost looks like this is an old
attribute of of human self-interest and
human nature we tend
to not want to blame ourselves for very
much at all we tend to look for other
excuses for things and none of the other
suggestions about what might have
happened other than
humans probably entered a continent with
animals that were completely naive about
us and in the time that it took them to
smarten up and confront us we were able
to scatter them enough that what we kind
of think now is that we may have gotten
like populations of mammoths so
separated from one another that they
couldn't exchange their genes and they
may have succumbed to I don't know if
you've probably heard of what happened
to The Mamas on Wrangle Island there was
a group of mammoths out on an island in
the uh the sea off the coast of Alaska
that were caught by Rising Waters in the
Bering Sea and were isolated and
survived down to about 4 000 years ago
but even though humans never found them
even though the climate changed the
animals were fine until they finally
reached a point where they had a small
enough genetic diversity that as they
enter bread with one another over and
over again
mistakes began to build into their
genome to the point where they finally
became unable to reproduce wow and four
thousand years ago without any other
effect being present they died out do we
have
biological remains or skeletal remains
of Clovis people and
people from that that time period yeah
we do there's a
there's a actually a clovis burial site
in Montana of uh of two uh infants a
young child and an infant and they were
buried with ceremonial Clovis points
several inches long covered and sacred
what we think was sacred red ocher
and that particular site in 2014 uh the
local native people in Montana is near
Bozeman and the local native people and
uh and archaeologists
went out to the shields River the nearby
Shields River and after studying these
these these uh young skeletons they
reburied them in the shields River so
they returned them to the Earth in 2014.
so they reburied them in the same site
where they found them near the same site
yeah they were found yeah they were
found on the banks of the shields River
uh why not that's interesting that they
chose to do that because I can
understand why they would think to
respect the bodies and barium but I
could also understand like for science
like what an incredible Discovery yeah
well they they did do uh science on them
but was their genetic material was there
there was not no physical tissue no
marrow or anything not that I'm aware
you know and I could be wrong about that
but I don't think so do they have an
understanding of where these people
might have come from originally
they seem to have come yeah and again
because of we do have some uh some sites
uh I mean the close people ended up all
the way down into South America
and we do have genomic evidence from
some of the sites that have preserved
enough DNA
to make educated uh guesses about this
that their origin was probably the Lake
Baikal region in Siberia
and that they probably when the ice
sheets open they probably came down in
two different migrations